we spend so much of our lives trying to
fulfill our distant Ambitions wanting to
create the circumstances in which
finally we'll be happy we'll have worked
everything out organized our way of life
and finally would have reached a place
of contentment it is an enchanting idea
but ironically it means that most of the
time we are restless because we're not
there yet the present is just the
tedious dreary period we have to get
through until in the future we can
finally relax and enjoy ourselves
the unexpected companion that we perhaps
need to ease our frustration is a
respectable Greek speaking
middle-ranking civil servant Constantine
kavafi who was born in Alexandria in
1863. cavafi often felt displaced he
lived almost all his life in Egypt but
thought of himself as a citizen of
Byzantium once the capital of the
Eastern Roman Empire cavafi only hit his
creative stride in his 40s and published
little during his lifetime held back by
an anxiety that the overtly homoerotic
themes he often wanted to explore would
be met only with condemnation his poem
that has most to help us is usually
contained in a book of his collected
poems and is titled Ithaca
technically the island of Ithaca was the
home of the legendary Greek hero Ulysses
to which he spent 10 adventurous years
trying to return after the fall of Troy
but in this poem it signals whatever we
imagine our destination in life to be
it's the image we have in our heads of
the distant time when we'll finally be
able to live properly maybe once we
found a partner or bought a house or
secured a divorce or made a fortune or
retired
doesn't want to help us to get to Ithaca
more quickly instead he wants to delay a
rival as long as possible
as you set out for Ithaca he writes hope
your road is a long one then kavafi
invokes what he calls Harbors May there
be many summer mornings when with what
pleasure what Joy you enter Harbors
you're seeing for the first time
these emphatically are not our
destination they are the places and
things people and experiences we
encounter precisely because we're not
home yet and which won't any longer be
available to us when we finally get
there
cavafi's ideal is that when we arrive at
our home we may find that it is in many
ways poor that it has very little to
offer us he writes Ithaca gave you the
marvelous Journey without her you
wouldn't have set out
she has nothing left to give you now and
if you find her poor Ithaca won't have
fooled you wise as you will have become
if we live this way with a warm sense of
appreciation with a sense of adventure
with a willingness to explore byways our
destination when we get there won't be
the big fulfillment we once expected it
to be we'll have found our fulfillment
along the way it won't be what we find
at the end that pleases us so much as
what we bring with us it won't be
marriage making money or retiring that
in itself is so great what will matter
is what we have discovered in ourselves
before we have reached these
destinations